hello and welcome to mel simplified in
this video we will discuss about the
krebs cycle
I posted a brief video on the topic of
Krebs cycle a few years back and that
was a hugely popular video among you
guys so this will be an update to that
video in which we will discuss Krebs
cycle in more detail but in a simplified
way at least I'll try to so let's begin
Krebs cycle is also known as a hands
Krebs cycle or the citric acid cycle now
hands after the scientists who
discovered it hands
Adolphe Krebs in 1937 and received a
Nobel Prize for Physiology and medicine
in 1953
now this cycle is also known as a citric
acid cycle after the molecule that plays
the central role in kreb cycle the
citric acid also known as the citrate
the citric acid cycle is a key metabolic
pathway that connects carbohydrate fat
and protein metabolisms the TCA cycle is
a central pathway into which many
metabolites feed it consists of a number
of reactions we generate nadh and fadh2
which are in turn used to generate ATP's
the krebs cycle consists of a series of
chemical reactions that release stored
energy of fats carbohydrates and
proteins through the chemical process of
oxidation other than being the central
pathway for generation of energy the
kreb cycle is also very important as it
provides many raw materials that are
used elsewhere in the body like amino
acids and NADH an interesting fact about
the Krebs cycle is that it was one of
the earliest established components of
cellular metabolism and may have
originated a biogenic li meaning it
originated
even before the life started this is the
concept of abiogenesis that the life
originated from nonliving things get the
lecture handouts from this video and all
other videos on meth simplified join our
community at patreon.com or click the
join button below now before diving into
all the chemical names the enzymes and
the various steps of Krebs cycle
I would like to take a few minutes to
talk about the conceptual basis of Krebs
cycle that most teachers failed to
explain so like I told you Krebs cycle
is a central metabolic pathway now what
do you mean by a central metabolic
pathway now see when we eat food it is
digested absorbed and is first processed
by initial metabolic pathways these
initial metabolic pathways generate some
common products that are used by the
central pathway like the Krebs cycle to
produce energy like if we take the
example of carbohydrates carbohydrates
are digested into simple sugars like
glucose and the glucose is first
processed by initial metabolic pathways
like glycolysis glycolysis produces
pyruvate and similar products are
produced by the initial metabolism of
fats and proteins as well the pyruvate
is then fed into the central pathway
that is the Krebs cycle so the Krebs
cycle provides a central pathway that
connects carbohydrate fat and protein
metabolisms
now the next important concept is how
does the kreb cycle produce energy for
this let's take the example of
metabolism of carbohydrates again we get
simple sugars at the end of digestion of
carbohydrates like glucose right and
after this glucose under goes through
all the metabolic pathways like
glycolysis kreb cycle and electron
transport chain one molecule of glucose
produces approximately 36 ATP's but
where does this energy come from the
single body the answer to this question
is through the chemical process of
oxidation now see what happens is that
through glycolysis and an additional
reaction we break down glucose into
small two carbon fragments which are
known as acetate this acetate is then
fed into the Krebs cycle if you look at
the kreb cycle it consists of these ten
intermediate molecules that start and
end with citrate when we add acetate to
this cycle this is a two carbon compound
this cycle takes a full turn and
releases two molecules of carbon dioxide
as a waste product
meaning the two carbons that we added in
the form of acetate are released in the
form of carbon dioxide this carbon
dioxide is produced due to the process
of oxidation that occurs in the Krebs
cycle as a result of various enzymes
electrons are added to nad to make nadh
and fadh2 and are then subsequently used
in the electron transport chain to make
ATP through ionic gradients now all of
this may seem a bit confusing in the
beginning but my advice is to take
things slowly was the other videos
regarding glycolysis electron transport
chain and metabolism of fats on our
channel to have a complete understanding
of this metabolic pathway the links to
all these videos are in the description
below meanwhile let's begin with the
details of the krebs cycle and various
enzymes involved so in eukaryotic cells
the citric acid cycle occurs in the
matrix of the mitochondria in the
prokaryotic cells such as bacteria which
lack mitochondria the citric acid cycle
is performed in the cytosol
now there is a very important reason why
a CREP cycle takes place in the center
of the mitochondria this is because of
the presence of the electron transport
chain in the membrane of the
mitochondria this electron transport
chain is a chain of many different
enzymes that uses the products formed in
the kreb cycle to produce energy in the
form of ATP
now to learn more effectively about the
Krebs cycle it is very important that
you have a little bit of background
knowledge about the preceding steps that
happened before Krebs cycle
so the kreb cycle begins with this
molecule as a takeaway but where does
this come from
and what is its role in the kreb cycle
this is very important to understand now
one of the important biochemical
pathways that runs before the kreb cycle
is glycolysis
in this pathway we break down glucose
which is a six carbon compound into two
molecules of pyruvate which is a three
carbon compound what happens next is
that this pyruvate is acted upon by a
set of enzymes collectively known as a
pyruvate dehydrogenase complex in this
reaction coenzyme a is also involved
which is a coenzyme derived from vitamin
b5 in this reaction two carbons are
transferred from the pyruvate to
coenzyme a to form the acetyl co a one
additional carbon present in the
pyruvate is lost in the form of carbon
dioxide in this reaction one molecule of
NADH is also produced so this is how
acetyl co a is produced from pyruvate
this acetyl CoA is a two carbon compound
and is the starting point of Krebs cycle
in this molecule the coenzyme a the part
which is derived from vitamin b5 acts
just like a carrier which transfers the
two carbons attached to it to the Krebs
cycle
so the first step of the Krebs cycle is
the combination of acetyl co a with
oxaloacetate like I told you
acetyl co a is a two carbon compound and
this two carbon compound combines with
observe acetate which has four carbons
this combination leads to formation of
citrate which is a six carbon compound
and this reaction is made possible by
the enzyme citrate synthase the name of
this enzyme is self-explanatory for what
it does the citrate then undergoes a
series of enzyme catalyzed reactions in
which it loses the two carbons of acetyl
co a in the form of two molecules of
carbon dioxide the conversions which
involve up to ten chemical reactions are
all brought about by enzymes which use
energy generated through oxidase
to attach electrons to nad and fa D now
let's look at what happens next with
citrate in the next two reactions the
citrate is converted into its isomer
which is known as isocitrate both these
reactions which I have shown with just
one arrow are catalyzed by the enzyme
equalities now this is an iron
containing enzyme which reorganizes the
atoms of citrate to form an isomer
isocitrate now you may ask what was the
need to convert citrate into isocitrate
why can't the citrate just move forward
with the pathway well the answer to that
is that the arrangement of atoms in the
isocitrate is better suited for the next
few excision reduction reactions that
are about to come in the Krebs cycle in
the isomerization of citrate to
isocitrate and intermediate is also
generated which is known as sis
Akane Tate but no need to go into the
details of that moving on to the next
step in the Krebs cycle in the next step
the isocitrate is converted into alpha
ketoglutarate by the enzyme isocitrate
dehydrogenase now we come to the first
of the for oxidation reduction reactions
in the citric acid cycle these oxidation
reduction reactions are the one which
produce energy in Krebs cycle and all of
these four reactions use enzymes in them
which are known as dehydrogenases now
what do these dehydrogenase is do and
how do they produce energy that is very
important for you to understand see if
you look at the term itself
dehydrogenase this literally means
removal of hydrogen so dehydrogenases
are basically enzymes that remove
hydrogen from a molecule now as you
remember that removal of hydrogen is
also known as oxidation and the hydrogen
that is removed from one molecule must
be passed on to some other molecule the
other molecule that receives the
hydrogen gets reduced in return so this
is the basic mechanism of action of
dehydrogenases they remove hydrogen
group from one molecule oxidizing it and
in turn attaching that hydrogen group to
some other molecule leading to its
reduction this is why the reactions
carried out by dehydrogenases are known
as
reduction reactions so coming back to
our Krebs cycle we reached a point in
crab cycle where isocitrate will now be
acted upon by the enzyme isocitrate
dehydrogenase so let's look at what
happens in this reaction this is
actually a two-step reaction in which
the enzyme isocitrate dehydrogenase
first removes hydrogen from isocitrate
thus oxidizing it the hydrogen that is
removed is attached to nad to form the
NADH thus completing the process of
oxidation and reduction but there is a
small additional step that happens next
which is catalyzed by the same enzyme
isocitrate dehydrogenase in the next
step of the reaction a carbon atom is
also removed from isocitrate in the form
of a molecule of carbon dioxide this
leads to the formation of a 5 carbon
compound known as alpha ketoglutarate so
if you look at a complete chemical
process that just happened here this is
known as the oxidative decarboxylation
oxidative because oxidation of
isocitrate takes place since a hydrogen
is removed from isocitrate and
decarboxylation as a carbon group is
also removed from isocitrate the
conversion of isocitrate into alpha
ketoglutarate is followed by a second
oxidative decarboxylation reaction the
formation of succinylcholine obliterate
this reaction uses the enzyme alpha
ketoglutarate dehydrogenase that
catalyzes a similar oxidative
decarboxylation of alpha ketoglutarate
in this reaction also a hydrogen gets
attached to nad to form the NADH since
it is also a type of decarboxylation a
carbon is removed from alpha
ketoglutarate to be lost in the form of
carbon dioxide also coenzyme a is used
in this reaction therefore the product
will be a combination that is known as
succinylcholine
in the next step of the kreb cycle the
succinylcholine volted to succinate this
reaction is catalyzed by the enzyme
known as succinylcholine Thetis now try
to understand what happens here in this
reaction as this is a very important
concept and often missed by many
students the number of carbons remain
the same in this reaction both 16 Alcoa
and succinate have four carbons each so
what changes 16 Elko is a high energy
compound and the energy stored in this
compound is used to attach an inorganic
phosphate molecule to GDP this GDP gets
converted to gtp which is like a close
cousin of ATP and is later used in the
formation of an ATP the coenzyme a
attached to the succinylcholine in this
reaction so what happens here
essentially is that the succinylcholine
uses its high free energy and it's
coenzyme a to be converted into
succinate and a molecule of gtp
this is an example of substrate level
phosphorylation a process of producing
energy that we discussed in detail in
our glycolysis video
so now we have four carbon compound
known as succinate in fact the number of
carbons do not change from here onwards
all the compounds which come next in the
cycle only have four carbons the last
compound generated in the cycle is
oxaloacetate which also has four carbons
and that of zero acetate combines with
another molecule of acetyl co a to form
citrate a starting point of the krebs
cycle coming back to where we left the
cycle so we have succinate which is a
four carbon compound and it is acted
upon by the enzyme succinate
dehydrogenase as you can tell from its
name this enzyme is a dehydrogenase so
it removes hydrogen from succinate and
the hydrogen that is removed is accepted
by flavin adenine dinucleotide or fa d
fa d is in turn converted to fadh2
succinate gets converted to fumarate fa
d is the hydrogen acceptor in this
reaction and not nad because attaching
hydrogen to nad requires more energy
then this reaction can provide so FA D
is used here as it requires less energy
change to get reduced to fadh2 energy
change for four carbon compounds is less
as compared to six or five carbon
compounds that were present at the first
half of the cycle there is however an
exception to this at the end of the
cycle that we will discuss in a bit
now the enzyme involved in the
conversion of succinate to fumarate is
succinate dehydrogenase which like
equalities is an iron sulfur protein
this enzyme is also very important as
succinate dehydrogenase is directly
associated with the electron transport
chain the next step in the Krebs cycle
is a hydration reaction which means we
add a molecule of water to fumarate and
convert it into malate this reaction is
catalyzed by the enzyme fume arrays
nothing special in this reaction so
let's move on to the next one the next
type of reaction that happens here is
oxidation in which we finally oxidize
malate to oxaloacetate and the enzyme
involved here is again a dehydrogenase
which is known as the malate
dehydrogenase again the nad molecule
gets reduced
to nadh which will be used in the
electron transport chain in this
reaction nad gets reduced to NADH now
you may ask why nad gets reduced here
and not F ad because like I told you
earlier that the free energy change for
compounds in the end of the cycle is
less as compared to that that was
present at the first half of the cycle
well this was the exception that I was
talking about even though this reaction
is present at the end of this cycle
still a molecule of nad is getting
reduced here well this is due to the
fact that oxaloacetate that is being
produced here is rapidly being utilized
by combining it with acetyl co a to form
citrate and the second product being
produced here the NADH is also being
rapidly used in the electron transport
chain
so the standard free energy for this
reaction unlike that for the other steps
in the citric acid cycle is
significantly positive I know that some
students especially in lower grades may
find some of the concepts I explained
here a little advanced but trust me you
will have to learn about the cycle in
depth at one point or another so better
now the oxaloacetate again combines with
a molecule of acetyl co a and leads to
the formation of citrate with the help
of the enzyme citrate synthase a water
molecule is also added in this reaction
but this completes one full turn of the
cycle and the same sequence repeats
again
okay so if we look at the cycle now you
can see that because what we got from
this cycle we added two carbons to the
cycle in the form of a molecule of
acetyl co a these two carbons were
released in the form of two molecules of
carbon dioxide here and here in this
process of oxidation and reduction we
convert three molecules of nad to NADH
one molecule of fa D to F ADH and we
converted one molecule of gdp to GTP now
there are few other important concepts
regarding the kreb cycle that you must
understand to have a complete knowledge
about this biochemical cycle the first
is this summary reaction of this cycle
and the second is the energetics of the
cycle meaning how many ATP's are
produced for every one molecule of
glucose that enters the cycle so first
coming to the summary reaction of
glycolysis now the net reaction of
citric acid cycle is one molecule of
acetyl co a plus three molecules of nad
plus one molecule of F ad plus one
molecule of GTP plus one molecule of
inorganic phosphate plus two molecules
of water combined to give two molecules
of carbon dioxide and three molecules of
NADH plus one molecule of GTP and one
molecule of coenzyme a what is the
gibberish well let me decode this
reaction for you on the left-hand side
of this reaction are the raw materials
that are being used here and on the
right hand side are the products that
are formed in the kreb cycle now in
every single turn of the Krebs cycle we
use one molecule of acetyl CoA
that combines here with the absolvo
acetate to form citrate three molecules
of nad are used in the kreb cycle that
get reduced to three molecules of NADH
here you can see where the three nadh
molecules are produced in the Krebs
cycle 1 f ad molecule is used which gets
reduced to one molecule of F ADH this
fadh2 produced in the conversion of
succinate to fumarate here 2 molecules
of carbon dioxide are produced for every
one molecule of acetyl co a that enters
the Krebs cycle like i showed you
earlier 1 coenzyme a is produced in the
conversion of succinylcholine 8 where
succinylcholine uses the coenzyme a and
1 molecule of gdp combines with one
molecule of inorganic phosphate and
leads to the formation of one molecule
of GTP two molecules of water are
consumed 1 in the synthesis of citrate
and one hair in the hydration of
fumarate
okay so this was about the summary
reaction of crap cycle now let's talk a
little bit about how much energy is
produced in the Krebs cycle
most of the energy that is produced in
the Krebs cycle is via the reducing
equivalence the nadh and fadh2 are
subsequently utilized in the electron
transport chain if you look at the
placement of these two pi o chemical
pathways in the mitochondria they live
very close to each other the krebs cycle
operating in the matrix of the
mitochondria and the electron transport
chain in the membrane of the
mitochondria so the nadh and fadh2 are
being produced by the Krebs cycle are
easily utilized in the electron
transport chain for the production of
ATP now the details of how these ATP's
are produced in the electron transport
chain and how many ATP's are produced
are here in this video about electron
transport chain on our channel in a
nutshell you can remember that about 2.5
ATP's are produced by one NADH and 1.5
ATP's by one molecule of FA th
like we discussed in the summary three
nadh are produced through one turn of
Krebs cycle and one NADH
so three NADH and one fadh2 assign ATP's
in total in electron transport chain
plus we also have one ATP that is
directly produced in the kreb cycle
actually GTP is produced in the Krebs
cycle here and this GTP is further
utilized to convert an ADP to ATP
directly thus one asset alkaway unit
generates approximately 10 molecules of
ATP through one turn of crap cycle since
previously in glycolysis one glucose was
split into two pyruvate which were
further converted into two acetyl co a
molecules which entered the Krebs cycle
so 20 ATP's are produced per molecule of
glucose in the Krebs cycle
I hope you liked the video if you like
our content make sure to support us so
that we can keep making videos like this
you can support us by joining a
community on patreon calm or clicking
the join button below by joining your
channel you get exclusive content like
handouts of this lecture and all other
lectures on our channel flashcards
behind the scenes of these videos early
notifications exclusive posts and much
more thank you so much for watching